What is your coolest scar?
My coolest scar?
That's actually a really good question.
Oh my goodness.
I just have to do that randomly and just, I'm okay, okay, wait.
Does the scar have to do with a broken neck?
I have a scar on the back of my calf.
OK.
I don't know if it's cool, but it's large.
It's very large.
How did it happen?
I was in...
I'm sensing a lie here.
Temecula.
I was in Temecula...
I was in Temecula doing a horse show.
Were you riding the horse?
Yes.
Like a dressage or something?
Yeah, eventing.
Eventing.
Yeah.
And I was at the house for the weekend up there, an Airbnb,...
...and I was taking a shower after a long day,...
...and I tried to sit down in the shower and the back of my calf touched...
...like a little thing that was producing steam in the shower...
...and I got a second degree burn.